saudi court has scrapped the death
sentences of suspects in the killing of
dissident journalist
jamal khashoggi five people were given
reduced
terms of 20 years jail three others
received from
seven to ten years a top un official
slammed the move
saudi prosecutor performed one more act
today in this parody of justice
but these verdicts carry no legal or
moral legitimacy
they came at the end of a process which
was neither fair nor just or
transparent in may khashoggi's family
said they forgave his murders was
changed a lot it cleared the way for the
revised
sentences under islamic law but the
journalists fiances know commented on
the trials
calling it a complete mockery of justice
the shoji was seized in 2018 while
visiting the saudi consulate in turkey
who reportedly get papers for his
upcoming marriage
the journalist was allegedly dismembered
his remains have never been found
those centers to believe to have been
part of the hit squad sent to turkey
from riyadh
political analyst alessandro bruno told
us despite the horrific nature of the
crime
the west won't ensure justice
the fact that no official was tried
actually raises many more suspicions for
the world community the
opinion won't change the idea that the
saudi
government was behind it remains in fact
if anything
this sentence only proves it or at least
goes further into that direction
countries that deal with saudi arabia
on diplomatic and business levels won't
have
any technical formal reasons to halt
relations so whether while public
opinion will certainly be negative
at a technical level there will be no
sanctions
or other penalties that will impede
saudi arabia from working with other
countries